THEY SCORED.
THEY WANT THE WIN.
THE ISLANDER HAVE GOT TO GET IN
THE WIN CO
PAGEAU WHO ATONED FOR THAT.
MATTHEWS GOT TO IT.
DOWN THE BOARDS FOR MITCH  OFF
SLIPPING IN.
AND HE SCORESSWITH THE GOOD SPEE
PUCK AND SOROKIN'S NOT ABLE TO
GET ACROSS QUICK  CLEARING ATTE
FAILED.
PAGEAU LOOKS OFF THE PASS TO
H
STICK.
HE'S WIDE OPEN.
WANTS THE PUCK BUT NOT
TONIGHT.
>> Brendan: EIGHT SECONDS LEFT
ON THE SHORT-HANDED
GOAL.
>> Brendan: NYLANDER.
OFF THE SKATE OF AHO.
FAR SIDE FOR NYLANDER.
TAVARES.
PUEEM TO MAKE A
MISTAKE AT THE MOST CRITICAL
TIME AND PAYEPT IT IN THE
ZONE.
HERE'S BARZAL.
>> Butch: STANDS.IS OWN
TEAMMATE.ILLAC TRIVIA
REREVEAL AND TWEET MAKE IS IT V
DIFFICULT.
FWRRPT ISLANDERS TRAPPED IN
THEIR OWN NET.ENA.
ON THE ICE WITH BEAUVILLIER AND
>> Butch: ANOTHER GREAT
OPPORT CHANGE.
>>ONE TIME.
BROCK NELSON WASN'T ABLE TO
CARRY THEMORE.
MUZ WINN A BIT OF A SCREEN SHOT
ALL THE WAY ACROSS SOSOPERIOD.
SEBASTIANPARISE.
RITCHIE BACK IN.
NICK RITCHI
LILJEGREN.
>>
ARE BOTH RIGHT AROUND A MINUTE
IN: HE HAD TO PUT IT ON
HIS FOREHAND.
DIDN'T WANT TO GO ON HIS THAT'S
START SALO WITH THE SHOT.
HOLL LEANS ON HIM.
TA HANDLED THERE BY JOSEPH
WOLL.
>> Butch: G G
BETTER AT MANIPULATING IT IN
TERMS OFF
PARISE'S BACK IN.
NEVER MADE IT TO THE NET.ORETARE
THIRD.
CLOSED CAPTIONING PROVIDED BY
MADISON SQUARE GARDEN NETWORKS
TO THE FRONT!
THEY
ISLANDERS ARE A LITTLE SLOW TOS.
PAGEAU COULDN'T SPRING
BEAUVILLIER.SS.
PAGEAU COULDN'T THEY SCORE.
BUNTING WAS TRYING TO RETURN THP
UP.
THERE'S THE TRANSITION.
THE ISLANDER DEFENSE GETS CAUGHT
IN BETWEEN.
SOROKIN A LITTLE BIT DEEP